[Music]
[Applause]
Montana is a landlocked state it blows
my mind every day but there is waves in
the river and you can surf them on
surfboards just like you would in the
ocean we have a huge surf culture here
in Missoula my name is Kevin Ben Hart
Brown I go by KB and I own strong water
mountain surf company we are the
original Mountain surf shop and still
the only surf shop in the state of
Montana
I mean it's cowboy country here surfing
is in my soul on my very first earliest
memories at the age of three is visiting
my grandparents in San Diego and seen
surfing in the ocean and for whatever
reason I've been kind of searching for
surfing my whole life and I happened to
be here in Missoula Montana and tapped
into river surfing in the river it's a
standing wave so the wave is essentially
stationary you're going back and forth
across the wave but the wave is kind of
in one place the water is coming at you
it's pretty amazing
you know we'd built a really strong
River surf community here there's just a
ton of support and good vibe or good
energy this whole connection nature
correlates directly with kind of that
same vibe that you get in the ocean not
a lot of people know about river surfing
but there's River surfing communities
popping up everywhere and it's just
starting to explode for me personally
it's about doing what people don't think
you can do and proving that you can do
it and you know just getting out and
having a good time sharing the sport
it's exciting and fun to be an audience
whole new frontier